have you ever wondered what's inside the
Tesla app well today I share that and
some hidden features with you basic menu
shows you everything you need to know
and at the very top it has all of your
account settings including all of your
personal information and the way you
like to set up your Tesla if you come
back out you have full control over your
car and if you want to know the tire PSI
you can simply click up the top or hit
any of the quick functions at the bottom
you also have full control over the
climate System including your heated
seats biodefense mode and Camp mode
directly from the app if you want to
schedule your charging for only off-peak
charging or a certain time you can do
that inside the security and Driver
section is very minimal not much to talk
about but you do have an updated feature
in your charge stats which now allows
you to view months years and also set up
your exact cost of charging so you
always know a great hidden feature is
you can customize the controls at the
top by simply pressing and holding and
then dragging until you've got the
desired customized controls at the top